good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to the inaugural design future
Symposium here in Singapore
yes give it up
my name is Dawn Lim and I'm the
executive director of the design
Singapore Council we are the organizer
of Singapore design week I hope you have
been joining us in the last five days
the mirror Dev activities and events
that we've had across Singapore today's
Symposium is jointly organized with sutd
design Z and I'm absolutely delighted to
see all of you in person here today now
for those of you who've flown in from
abroad to join us many of our speakers
some of our friends from the media I
appreciate you've battled travel chaos
and engine failures and jet lag to be
here so thank you for making it and
staying awake today
now our theme for today is Agency for
the future design and the Quest for a
better world
like many countries all over the world
Singapore faces complex and pressing
issues that contemporary to our time
Urban density trying to put five and a
half million and the growing population
on an island that's 750 square
kilometers
an aging demographic with a fertility
rate that continues to remain low over
the years
climate change and rising sea levels for
an island that is low lying
widening inequality and challenges to
access
similar to many maturing economies and
developed economies around the world and
all of these are set against a rapid
technological innovation and
acceleration context that we've never
seen before
we are looking at an imminent future of
living
in the spatial internet with the
onslaught of web 3 Technologies right
before us
and these complex issues demand
and empathetic human-centered design
approach
design is a Force for good design can be
impactful and design can have long
lasting good effects and outcomes on our
society our economy and the world now
for those of you who've been around here
for a while you like you know we like to
say Singapore is a nation by Design
our history our geography our resource
limitations have always forced us to
innovate at the edge push the boundaries
to Prototype at the micro level but also
at the systems level
so that we can design a city-state
that is forward-looking futuristic and
cutting edge
and through this process of Designing a
nation
I'm really proud to say I really believe
we have developed a unique brand of
creativity and design that has allowed
us to be recognized as a UNESCO city of
design
and so it is critical that a design
Festival like ours focuses not just on
the future of design
but the design of the future as well our
vision for Singapore is to be an
innovation driven economy and a lovable
City by Design
we want to infuse design into every way
we work live and play so that we can
make Singapore and the world a better
place
I believe that we have a unique point of
view about the design of the future and
the future of design
and I think we should take that point of
view out to the world to inspire more
people to embrace design as a vehicle of
change in a vehicle of impact and so I
hope today will catalyze dialogue
discussions thought
around how all of us can embrace the
challenges of this shared future I
talked about
and to create a better world by Design I
leave you with this image of Singapore
one of my favorites but also a very
common one ten years ago this did not
exist
this is the future
this was by Design
everything is by Design
on that note allow me to introduce and
hand off to the festival director of
Singapore design meet 2022 Mr Mark we
mark
there we go
all right thanks for all Don for the
introduction
uh warm welcome to all of you all here
this afternoon my name is Mark I'm the
festival director of Singapore design
week 2022. created by Paula Antonelli
the Symposium is actually a key event
this week and we are really thankful for
all the support from all the media and
the partners that we have here
I'm also extremely grateful to hear that
this Symposium has sold out with a long
waiting list
I knew what's important
from the from the number of CEOs and
Senior public servants attending today
but I knew was really important
when even my wife decided to come this
afternoon
I think this speaks volumes not only in
terms of the caliber of the speakers but
also the relevance and urgency of the
topics that we're going to be discussing
today but these sessions will also be
recorded and we'll share them on our
digital and social platforms shortly
after
for the supporters of the past editions
of Singapore design week you'll notice
that this year we actually have
introduced three defining pillars of the
festival's renewed Vision design Futures
design Marketplace and design impact and
the symposia today is actually a key
feature of the design Futures pillar
through conversations with global and
local thought leaders it was really
clear that Singapore is a
forward-looking city state with a
genuine opportunity to prototype a
better future for Singapore and for the
world
if you did not know the Netflix series
Westworld was shot in Singapore
because renowned Danish architect biak
Engels who was actually recently part of
the design team that did at Capitol
Springs building downtown
told the creators that if you had to
shoot the future
it's right here in Singapore
so Paula Antonelli a friend of the
councils for many years
shared this firm conviction that
Singapore was actually in a natural
position to contribute to the larger
Global discourse on how we can live more
sustainably in the future
out of that relationship Paula
generously agreed to curate the future
Symposium that you see and you'll see to
that this afternoon
as well as one of the most
well-respected curatorial design voices
in the world today Paula has dedicated
her career to changing the perception of
design so that people are aware of the
desire of the importance of design in
everyday life and that design in her
words is more than cute chairs
I'm beyond thrilled to hear from her and
the panel like steam speakers that will
line up for the day and judging by the
sellout crowd I'm sure you'll agree with
me that the Symposium is really a unique
opportunity to share the world that
design can be a critical Ally
to our planet and Humanity's future in a
world map by technological change
geopolitical and instability and climate
change so once again I would like to
thank Paula and all the other speakers
for being here to share with us on how
design can help us Build a Better World
and please join me in introducing pal on
stage
[Applause]
thank you very much Don thank you Mark
and it's such a delight to be here and
thanks also to the two superheroes
actually more than two but especially
narel yabuka and Judea Chong that are
backstage and kind of put everything
together so an Applause to them please
yeah
okay
and we're standing in front of practice
theories great graphics Singaporean
Design Studio One of it was a tough
choice but they were definitely
wonderful I looked at so many of the
work of Design Studios here and that
just goes to confirm what I've always
thought about Singapore it's a paradise
for design Buffs so it's really
wonderful to be here a few nights ago
Mark asked me what do you want to take
away from the Symposium what would be
success for you and I told you you know
Mark mi casa is su casa your agenda is
my agenda and it's Don's agenda it's
Jacqueline Poe's agenda it's everybody's
agenda is to make sure that we explain
to the world how design can be used
better to be really part of a
conversation that involves policy making
that involves planning the future that
involves really making things happen
because as Don told you before today
we're here from many different fields of
course there's design Buffs but there's
academics there's Scholars there's
government planners there's like social
civil servants everybody is here because
we believe that design unites and brings
together teams that can be really
effective to build the future and that's
really what designers do not to mention
the design comes in so many different
facets yet it's not only cute chairs of
course and it is many it's interface
design it's Urban Planet it's
infrastructure planning architecture is
a branch of design in my uh in my
parlance and I can say it I know it
sounds a little Blasphemous to some but
I'm an architect so I kind of can say so
with this in mind and in Singapore we
call the Symposium Agency for the future
it's a little bit tongue-in-cheek
because I think that Singapore is the
only place in the world I've encountered
where being a civil servant is akin to
being a rock star and I was telling last
night that to Professor Ling cheong won
but truly it's a place where agencies
really act where they really implement
the future the openness with which you
talk about the issues that you have and
how they can be solved or how they
should be approached is refreshing and
is not found in many places in the world
so Agency for the future at the same
time we also want to prove that agency
is within each one of us I believe that
my role as a curator is not to tell
people what's good and what's bad but
rather to make sure that I stimulate
everybody everyone's critical sense and
curiosity so that every citizen can have
more agency more power to demand more to
push back to participate and to really
feel invested in the future that we are
planning so it really is important to
attack the future this way with a
multi-disciplinary approach that looks
at systems and this leads me to another
quintessential characteristic of
Singapore as Don said I and I started
being a friend of the design Singapore
Council and as Mark also reminded many
years ago that's when I also met piachu
who's here in the audience because the
panel that was organized by the design
Singapore helped advise the what was
then Mika the ministry of information
culture and the Arts on many different
issues and we would be brought here once
a year to discuss different subjects but
there was one recurrent topic how do we
make Singapore The Hub of the health
system in Southeast Asia the banking
system in the world it's like it was
always Hub Hub Hub Hub and you know
what's the essence of a hub it's being
part of a system and that was once upon
a time where some cities in the world
thought they were the center of the
world you know it was New York it was
London it was Hong Kong but nobody
thought yet of the importance of not
being number one but rather being many
number ones at different levels and now
that we're talking about web3 that we're
talking about distributed assets that
we're talking about disseminations and
systems hubs and spoke are the most
simplistic representation of a system
Singapore has always seen itself as part
of the system and its complexity is a
complexity by Design as you might know
Singapore has the most complex economy
in the world together with Switzerland
it's an economy that is at the same time
a way to harness one's fragility and
vulnerability and to strengthen One
Nation as the most important not really
soft power but like meta power that can
exist so from all geopolitical and
economical viewpoints Singapore can
really be the Hub one of the most
important hubs of the future and that's
what we really wanted to highlight with
this program I'm gonna tell you some of
the things that you need to know about
today before before we launch into the
important
panels that we have so the Symposium
will be split into three blocks there
will be punctuated by what food and
drinks so we're starting now then there
will be a coffee break then we will hear
another section dinner break and then
Grand Finale and each of these segments
will be indicated also on the screen and
uh we will be involved presentations
there will be presentations and
discussions it will be very varied one
of our speakers unfortunately could not
come at the last minute because of the
family emergency that's not say Audrey
cheza but she will join us on Zoom so
everything will be okay we've already
done all the tests and during each panel
discussion you will be able to ask
questions via the pigeonhole platform
and at the end when we'll have the
discussion your questions will be
filtered to narelle who will filter them
to me and I will make sure that at least
one of the questions will come from you
so you you this month you have received
an email from Eventbrite containing a
link to pigeonhole so you can use your
mobile devices to go to
pigeonhole.at and the key of the event
the passcode is DFS all caps 2022. I
think yeah I don't have it behind me but
DFS design future Symposium 2022 and
maybe you have already scanned the QR
code at the beginning so you know
already how to handle that but with this
said we're going to launch into a really
diverse set of panels and some quick
presentations just
maintain attention and don't try to
remember everything just remember the
impulses also this whole Symposium will
be online after us afterwards so you'll
be able to just uh go back and look at
all the different uh things that you
might have missed what is really
important is that we're gonna leave you
wanting for more uh We're not gonna
answer all the questions at all but
we're gonna show how Singapore is asking
the right questions you know it's not
giving out the answers yet but it's
asking the right questions questions
that could be extrapolated by many in
the outside world Singapore is a curator
like I am and does not try to tell the
world what's to what to do but rather to
stimulate the world to look at the
future in a way that is curious and
constructive